how often do you work with writers who
are afraid that their ideas will be
stolen almost every student I have
almost every client I have in my
coaching business has expressed concern
about what have my ideas got stolen and
how do I protect my ideas so a lot of
what I teach especially around week six
and week seven of the entertainment
business school is how do you protect
yourself how do you go in armed so that
you really understand the language of
the business side of the industry
and ultimately of course you cannot
copyright an idea and that's why some
production companies will have you sign
something that says hey if we're going
to read your script we can't promise we
don't have another idea like this in
development I was a development exec for
a company called Inferno entertainment
and we made films like just friends with
Ryan Reynolds um we did the good night
with gwenneth palro and Penelope crw we
did a movie that I help put together
called Peaceful Warrior with Nick Noti
that was based Bas on IP and all the
time we were getting submissions from
Managers from producers from Agents and
we might have three or four scripts in
the read que that were about the devil
how are you going to protect an idea
okay maybe your Devil is a woman or
maybe your devil is young or old or
living on another cont I mean they're
all a different take on the devil so
that's an example of like okay you might
feel like oh my script is so original
and it says take on the devil we've
never seen but I'm like oo I got four of
them here in the read que what is
undeniable is your voice as a writer is
your um your actual work your screenplay
your treatment which you can register
with the writer's Guild which you can
also um put into the Library of Congress
so those protections to get the writer
Guild protection to get the Library of
Congress protection on your work is huge
but you actually cannot copyright and
protect just an idea so you got to do
the work what do you teach students
about
IP okay so I love teaching about IP I'm
also a published novelist a lot of
experience in the publishing side of
things and as a development exec I was
was looking for IP so when I found the
book Peaceful Warrior that I had loved
as a teen and then went oh I wonder
what's happening with this my boss had
said go find us some IP so I made some
phone calls I called the agent I didn't
know you could just call an author's
agent even as a development exact I was
like I could just pick up the phone and
call them okay so I did and the agent's
like oh yeah well Nick NTI has the
rights to Peaceful Warrior oh really oh
okay well let's contact Nick's office so
we reach out hey what's happening with
Peaceful Warrior oh there's a script oh
great well we might want to co-finance
that we were doing um some co-financing
with new line cinema at the time so they
send over the script we're like this
script is pretty good next thing you
know peaceful Warrior is getting made as
a film so exacts feel more confidence
when there is some Legacy to a project I
mean we're seeing this with huge
decisions now like that Jeff Bezos has
made at Amazon to pursue Lord of the
Rings it was like what a $400 million IP
acquisition so of course you're probably
not at Jeff Bezos level of acquiring IP
but I even instruct my students pick up
the phone if you have a book that you
love what if the rights are available
did know you can call the agent what so
I had a student last session Who Loved
this particular book series that had
elves in it and she's I I give anything
to adapt this oh but it's so popular I'm
sure it's not available she's already
talking herself out of it I said pick up
the phone and call the agent and let's
find out if the rights are available the
rights were available the agent was
excited to talk to her the author was
thrilled she had idea for the whole
series she pitched it to them hey this
is what I would love to do with it could
I possibly have the rights she didn't at
the time have the money to pay for an
option which always is more but she did
offer a shopping agreement a paid
shopping and they went for it and now
she controls this IP and she's able to
do her own adaptation and she acts so
she's looking for a role for herself
that she gets to write for herself but
now that she controls that IP that
becomes a Honeypot for execs who are
like oh wait it's based on IP this the
most powerful statement you can utter to
any buyer I have this project based on
IP based on bestselling IP and a lot of
cases a best-selling work has sold tens
of thousands of copies in a year it
doesn't have to be Millions some of the
books on the New York Times bestseller
list have sold 40,000 50,000 copies and
maybe if it was a few years ago the
rights might be available so just to
encourage that you have the ability to
to contact book agents reach out to
authors directly I am working on an
adaptation of a memoir called swell I
reached out to the author directly
Captain Liz Clark I contacted her on
Instagram hey what's happening with your
book is there any plans for television
film adaptation and she said well I've
been waiting for the right team to come
along and the rights are available so
the author was ready to engage with me
directly that is the point when you have
a yes that is the point at which you
involve attorneys you find yourself a
great reliable entertainment attorney
hopefully someone who um comes from a
word of mouth recommendation where you
know okay there's someone I can trust to
put a contract together because you do
have to have a contract to control the
IP that's something I teach my students
in the entertainment business school
because it is a significant it is a
significant advantage in your career to
control
someip why is pitching important I think
writers all fall in love with the craft
all fall in love with the words on the
page and the story and their beloved
characters and then you realize oh no I
have to sell this somehow how do I
actually sell my work and that's usually
where uh the the plane runs out of
runway for a lot of writers oh wait what
do I do now and maybe they just go oh
I'm going to write another screenplay
next thing you they got 30 screen plays
so you have to learn pitching so many
writers like I don't want to be in sales
I don't have to sell anything that's why
I'm a creative Ka no I'm so sorry I have
to let you know that you are in sales
you're going to write things and then
you're going to need to take them out
and sell them you're always pitching so
whether you're talking to a producer at
a film festival or you're trying to get
representation you're pitching yourself
whether you're querying or you're
reaching out to others in your wolf pack
saying hey do you know anyone who might
be right for me you need to be able to
talk about yourself and your work
confidently because the first experience
that buyers so development execs and
producers people who can actually make
your show make your film have of you is
how well do you talk about your story
how well do you talk about your work and
I teach a technique called the stealth
pitch because it's quietly a pitch but
it makes it fun for the exec or the
producer to hear and they go tell me
more so I teach that to my writers in
the entertainment business school so
that they feel like okay I have some
arrows in my quiver to know how to talk
about myself there are other wonderful
teachers in the industry like Carol
kersner who I know you've had on your
show who teach pitching so well and
there's formatting around it that gives
you you know like in a bowling lane the
bumpers and you feel like oh I'm not
going to end up in the gutter you know
yeah you could can just head straight
for the strike how do you talk about
your story the world your personal
connection to that material if you're
pitching TV like this season future
Seasons you're letting them know really
essentially what you love about your
story so when I was a development exact
probably heard I don't know hundreds of
pitches what I will tell you is that we
never bought or financed a film where
there wasn't passion in the
pitch I a lot of half of the pitch
meetings I took the producers and
everybody who was there he got really
stiff and like really nervous okay we're
just going to we're going to tell you
about the story and these other
characters and and they look terrified
and they couldn't relax and just banter
oh I can't wait to tell you about my
favorite character because she you know
climbed Mount Everest at a time you know
when no women were doing that in her
flip-flops whatever it happens to be
right here look here's the axe that she
the the ice axe that she used to do it
and then the exact are like oh my gosh
you we feel connected so the passion to
can carry you far your energy your joy
Your Love of this story these characters
can carry you really far so you bring
the passion and then you start to learn
some of the structure and then you
practice and I will tell my students
always practice practice to yourself in
the mirror then put your phone on a
stand and film yourself talking about
your story talking about your work you
film it and then you go grab your spouse
grab your best friend grab somebody
you're working with and say hey would
you you got four minutes for me to just
I want to tell you this story and then
you put your phone up and you film
yourself pitching telling someone else
the story pitching is a little bit of
like a four-letter word for people who
go oh no it's sales I'm not salesy and
then they freeze and it gets scary but
if you find your passion and you can
communicate it and then tell a decent
story woven in you're already 90%
further down the road than someone who
can't clearly articulate with passion
the story that they're
telling